[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
so
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
please join me in the pledge i pledge
allegiance
oh god make speed to save us
[Music]
glory be to the father and to the son
and to the holy spirit
as it was in the beginning
amen let us pray
almighty and all-knowing god by whose
unsearchable wisdom the foundations of
the earth were laid
and the sons of men brought back from
the curse of death
to gloriously everlasting life with you
we come before you today with grateful
hearts for having finished the course
set before us these past years
we now humbly ask you for your
sustaining grace
to strengthen us by faith hope
and love for the path which lies now
ahead
empower us to hold fast and ever embrace
the blessed hope
of your everlasting kingdom that on the
last day we may rejoice
without fear to behold its appearing
when your son our lord jesus christ
returns in the clouds to reign on earth
as he does in heaven to whom with you
and the holy spirit
all glory lord and honor is due now
and forever amen please be seated for
the reading of scripture
the lesson is written in the fourth
chapter of saint paul's
second letter to timothy beginning at
sixth verse
for i am already being poured out as a
drink offering
and the time of my departure has come i
have fought the good fight
i have finished the race i have kept the
faith
henceforth there is laid up for me the
crown of righteousness
which the lord the righteous judge will
award me on that day
and not only to me but also to all who
have loved his appearing
here
please stand for the reading of the
fourth psalm we will read the psalm
responsibly by
every half verse the congregation saying
together in each molded line
hear me when i call o god of my
righteousness you set me free
when i was in trouble have mercy on me
and hear my prayer oh you children of
men
how long will you blast you my honor and
have
know this also that the lord has chosen
for himself
the one that
and sin is commune with your own heart
and be still offer the sacrifice of
righteousness
there are many that say who will show us
any good
lord lived up the life of your
countenance
you have put gladness in my heart more
than when others
i will lay me down at peace and take my
rest for you
lord make me dwell in savior
glory be to the father and to the son
and to the holy spirit
you may be seated
[Music]
uh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
just
[Music]
[Music]
says
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
jesus
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
sweeties
[Music]
tonight
[Applause]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Applause]
foreign
is
good morning
i confess that i am a little cowed by
all of this
having experienced in the chapel a few
times
it's not my nature exactly but uh
everything about this weekend is rich
with tradition and rich with the story
of
the nature of man this particular
ceremony is designed
to say goodbye to the seniors in the
presence of the lord
when we were designing this chapel we
imagined it like this
we mentioned it full full of people like
you
members of the college and their friends
and loved ones
and the friends and loved ones of the
college which is now many millions of
people
we imagine the members of the college
their friends and loved ones in certain
attitude the attitude we have now
it is an attitude of excitement
the culmination of major undertakings is
always exciting because the completion
of a thing
is the reason the thing is done the
harder the thing is to do
the more the outcome is consequential
the work that has been done here has
been very hard
and very worth it and very consequential
it is easy to see that the seniors have
come here to grow up
i always think we should bring some
freshmen in to sit in here too so we can
look at them and see that they still
look like high school kids
when you talk to them they giggle and
write
and the seniors are not like that
anymore
[Laughter]
let me amend that they're not all like
that anymore
[Laughter]
bridget down there is a big giggler
they are grown-ups they have built the
outlines of their understanding
which they must spend the rest of their
lives filling out
they will always be kids to me and those
old folks of us who work here
because we knew them when they were kids
and the child is the father to the man
and the daughter is the mother to the
woman
but this is now their place they're not
new anymore
they've made it their home their second
home
and like their first home it will always
be home
some of them will stay here because it
seems like all of them want to these
days
we throw some of them out because we
think they could be more used elsewhere
but
wherever they are this will be home
this will be the place where they grew
up
this growing up is fundamental it is the
natural end of
living beings all of them
the puppy struggles to become the dog
the acorn the oak tree the foal the
horse
these seniors have become adults men and
women who
are as the emperor says in star wars
fully operational death stars
the life they have before them will only
seem long at the beginning
they will however i hope have
established the habit of using everyday
well
because then it will be rich and only
then
they will remember this moment they will
remember sitting in here
it is most fit on this high day so full
of symbolism
we just went to the commissioning
ceremony for
two marines where are they
they uh yeah wherever they are
they're lost and
that is rich with symbolism it involves
oaths and pledges
this is the richest of all
because it is here in this place with
the lord
this growing up that we do that's
for us to become more completely what we
are
we never fully do that we humans only
god
does that we aim to be
like god which is impossible
and we aim to be with god which is
possible
and that means we have to get ourselves
ready
to be with god that is the whole point
of human life and the whole point of
hillsdale college
this is the third i'm reminded
baccalaureate service we've
held in this chapel the first one was
crazy because
i'm crazy we moved temporary furniture
in here
and had baccalaureate service because
i always have a soft spot for young
people
i couldn't keep my job up if i didn't
and they're all so pitiful
and if they all they had was the
construction project
and then never get to use the thing i
thought that would
it would be bad so we did come in here
and then last year we had one and you
know
the numbers were limited alas
and i didn't quite prepare
i didn't get was fully geared up to defy
that order
because i thought it'll be embarrassing
if the parents get arrested
i don't think it will be embarrassing if
i get arrested which is possible
but i thought no okay so we'll do this
social distancing now we're all here
i opine that it's legal although it's
almost impossible to know what's legal
these days
but this is the second time i've seen it
like this
the first time was when clarence thomas
dedicated it
and that's one of the great days of my
life we had imagined this
and and i was standing in the
queue out there listening to the
orchestra and the choir
amaze everyone here for the first time
and i leaned over and i looked out out
the window and i saw it like this
i saw it full and the fullness of it see
that is a vindication of what it is what
it's for it has drawn all of us here
and when i leaned over and looked i'd
confess it's
one of three times the chaplains made me
cry
and i looked back up and i started to
turn my head and justice thomas said to
me
don't look at me
i'll cry too
isn't it a privilege to get to do this
and to get to do it in here in the
presence of the lord
in a place built to suggest the presence
of the lord
isn't the things that we've been allowed
to do together they are so rare these
days and precious they've always been
rare
more now and you
you seniors you have chosen to do them
and you had lots of other options
so i congratulate you on that
i expect you to lead great lives
i expect you to be a blessing to
everyone you meet
and i hope that you will remember this
day as a commitment to that end
bless you all
henceforth there is laid up for me the
crown of righteousness
in the name of the father and of the son
and of the holy spirit
amen it's
a wonderful privilege to greet you here
today this is now also the third time i
have had this privilege
and to deliver this charge to you all as
we commend you to the lord this day
dr aaron spoke quite fittingly of
growing up
i'm going to speak to you today about
the other side of that coin
that will become apparent in a moment
one of my favorite stories from the
gospels occurs in luke chapter 2.
it involves a relatively minor character
who has made a disproportionately
massive impact
on the worship of god's people
throughout the world
i speak of an old man named simeon
we don't know much about his life what
he did for a living
who his family was if he had any
children what he accomplished
but what we do know about him and just a
few short verses in luke's opening
chapters
tells us certainly the most remarkable
thing there is to know about him
simeon had incredible
faith it was revealed to him in his
younger years that
he would not die before he saw the
messiah with his own eyes
and now so many decades later in his old
age he was as luke tells us
waiting for the consolation of israel
imagine my friends today if you would
the pains
of such a long waiting the patience
the perseverance required
on one particular day his patience was
paid off
he was moved by the holy spirit to enter
into the temple courts
and thereby what could only be described
as a supernatural provision
he was made able to recognize the christ
in his infancy when a jewish couple of
unremarkable appearance brought him in
their arms to dedicate him to god
according to the law of moses on the
40th day after his birth
you have to ask luke doesn't tell us you
have to ask how did
simeon know this ordinary looking child
was the long
promised messiah what kind of
boldness motivated this man to just walk
up to his unsuspecting parents and
take their child into his arms
what kind of imagination cultivated no
doubt by
years of patient prayer prepared him to
compose on the spot
that sublime him for which he is now
famous
all over the face of the earth
for when he took the child in his arms
he praised god saying
lord now let us thou thy servant
depart in peace according to thy word
for mine eyes have seen thy salvation
which thou hast prepared
before the face of all people
to be a light to lighten the gentiles
and to be the glory of thy people israel
and that's it that's simeon's part
in the story the narrative moves on
after that with nearly a word about him
but what a remarkable contribution
simeons is
consider my friends the power of these
few words his prayer
if you pay attention to it it's it's
essentially a request to god
to die it's not a suicide it's not a
despairing of this world oh no quite the
contrary it's rather a great hymn of
hope
of great confidence in the sureness
of god's promise of god's word
he's now unseen with his own eyes what
he was born by god to see
and that is enough for him
he's now happy to fall asleep in the
embrace of his god
his rock and his redeemer
lord now let us thou thy servant he
speaks of himself
let us thou thy servant depart he speaks
of his death
in peace
simeon's song has made it into the daily
prayers of god's people for many
centuries
in fact for over a millennia for over a
millennia and a half
it has been the wisdom of both eastern
and western christians to sing it
in the evening hours as part of their
daily prayer
in that particular spot in the evening
hours it signifies our unity with simeon
are sharing in his most blessed sight of
the christ the light
of the nations we are the nations we are
the beneficiary of simeon's song
and by that awareness of saying his
words nightly
reinforced every evening before we go to
sleep
simeon's words serve as a solemn charge
to us
that we prepare ourselves now for a good
and holy death
as simeon himself prepared
bedtime becomes then an occasion to
remember our deaths
to meditate on the judgment that will
then ensue
and to cultivate a heart of faith and
gratitude
that will in fact be pleased to meet
that hour
as a precious gift on the day that it
inevitably arrives
now you may well be asking why in the
world
am i talking right now about death
and here you are young and in your prime
getting to getting ready to take the
world by storm and to show it
a thing or two and i hope that you do
you are at peak efficiency my friends
it's all downhill from here
physically and mentally your dreams are
only just beginning to take shape
your paths are just opening up before
you your options
really are at this moment boundless
surely now is a time to charge you for
life
not death dr aaron speaks of growing up
i'm here to tell you about the other
thing
because alas where would be the fun and
not talking about it
to say nothing of the fact that one of
the principal ways of the holy
scriptures and in fact the wisdom of the
christian tradition as reflected in the
daily singing of simeon's song
every evening charge us to consider a
good life
is to remind us of life's end
consider psalm 90. may we count
our days a right and grow our hearts of
wisdom
and when we encounter that end as we all
certainly will
well maybe dr arn won't i don't know
what are the things that will make that
day a good one
perhaps you might put the matter this
way at this moment you are all busy
building your resumes i don't blame you
skills competencies accomplishments
that's all well and good for what it's
worth
but when it's time my friends for your
friends and family to remember you
what i ask will they focus on do you
think
what you did or
who you were for you were to them
who you were to those around you now
these two things of course cannot be so
easily sundered
but stating the matter this way has the
effect of amplifying what i'm after this
morning
character
a soul indelibly marked by the holy
spirit
to look like the lord christ
your character will be what is loved and
missed
and extolled in eulogies
and that is the fact in fact the only
thing that you can take with you
from this world
consider the apostle paul in today's
scripture lesson from his second letter
to his good friend and his student
timothy
paul is about to die
he knows it he sees it he sees clearly
the end of the road
the writing on the wall and his death
will not in fact be a peaceful one
in a posh florida retirement community
oh no
it will be a martyrdom at the end of a
toilsome and pain-filled
life at this moment as he shares
the present state of his soul to one of
his dearest companions
at this most vulnerable of moments what
does the apostle have to say about
himself
as he looks back on his life what is it
that gives him satisfaction
what is it that makes this a good end
his words my friends are remarkable
especially considering their context as
i just described it to you
i have fought the good fight i have
finished the race
surely this is a summation of all of his
accomplishments
is it not a bird's-eye view of his
resume right
certainly he has much to lists
he does so in fact in a couple of places
first corinthians 11 2nd corinthians 11
one of my favorites
also in philippians 3 he has endured
public beatings
these are the peculiar things he lists
in those places he has survived
shipwrecks he has navigated bitter
conflicts
he has established and nurtured many new
congregations
he has evangelized on two continents he
has raised up
leaders he has combated heresies he has
healed schisms
he has rebuked prominent public figures
i speak of course of the apostle peter
he has maneuvered through conspiracies
and whether he is aware of this
accomplishment
in these terms or not he has he has been
by god's grace
privileged to write sacred scripture
half
of the new testament my friends
what's a resume you should be so lucky
surely this is what he's celebrating in
his final moment is it not
no the crown jewel of it all
is how he concludes this short list how
he brings it to a climax
that core idea which defines the whole
and brings the rest into a right and
godly focus
i have fought the good fight i have
finished the race
i have kept the faith
this this is the apostle paul's greatest
comfort
in life and now here at the end in death
he has stayed true to his lord
he has done what he was commanded to do
he has fought for and maintained
steadfast devotion
within his own breasts to his lord and
savior
when all else is stacked up and weighed
this is by far
the crowning achievement of them all he
made it
his faith has remained aflame
his hope has endured his love has proven
steadfast
at the moment of death this
is all that matters to him
as we consider paul's resume here's a
litany of earthly accomplishments
are they not merely a monument to this
other thing
my friends how do you think the apostle
paul got there
do you think he just mustered up the
faith in this moment without
doing any heavy lifting beforehand do
you think that when he faced
mobs at ephesus or slanderers in
jerusalem
or false apostles in galatia that he
magically conjured up the character to
endure
in the heat of the crisis
how does paul emerge from prison with
his faith
unscathed from beatings
with his hope unshaken and from false
accusations
with his love unadulterated how does he
do this
there was nothing flippant about his
comforting words spoken at the end of
his life
nothing cheap as if easily gained he has
held
fast to his faith by persevering in the
word
and promise of god as simeon did before
him
he has nurtured his hope by a life of
prayer and thanksgiving
he has kindled his love
by service and by sacrifice
he has embraced the life of his lord
and our lord jesus christ by
consistently dying to his own
considering all of his earthly worth as
a loss
compared to the surpassing greatness of
knowing jesus christ and his death and
resurrection
philippians 3 8-10 he has striven to
know nothing in this life
but christ and him crucified first
corinthians 2 2.
and now as he stares down the barrel of
the last judgment
like simeon before him
he is not afraid
he is not ashamed he is not anxious
about the outcome he is not full of
regret
and contrition rather he says with
confidence my friends these words are
remarkable
henceforth there is laid up for me the
crown of
righteousness which the lord the
righteous judge will award me on that
day
henceforth has laid up for me the crown
of righteousness
the best is yet to come
did you consider that friends
did you catch the hope the optimism in
his words
when he considers the terrors of that
great white
throne of judgment when the books will
be opened and everyone's deeds will be
read forth the apostle paul
is actually looking forward to it
he knows that he will receive the crown
of victory
why because he has kept
the faith he has held fast
to the grace of the gospel he has
clothened tightly to the love
and atoning embrace of his lord and
savior
now i labor to impress this upon you now
because you are on the verge my friends
of a great embarkation
commencement as we rightly call it is
a beginning and not an end it is a
launching pad for the life
of which god has formed you and to which
god has called you
and right now you are full of excitement
and joy maybe a little anxiety if you're
honest though
perhaps anticipation is the better word
and you are right to be
but there is an urgency about the end
that perhaps has not fully hit you yet
at this moment of your life but it is no
less real even now
you think now you have all the time in
the world
but character of faith hope and love
does not come
cheaply or automatically in seasons of
challenge and deprivation
you have to work for it my friends right
now
you have to put in the exercise right
now or you can't win the race when the
finish line comes
you have to retr rototill the soil of
your soul right now
you have to cleave to the cross of jesus
christ your savior
right now and from every day forward
from this day hence
you have to prepare for the end now
the wisdom of the church teaches us this
in our nightly prayers
you have to work my friends on your
eulogy now
with a far greater urgency than you
build your resumes
because only that will actually motivate
you to live your life
as it's so lavishly laid before you now
to its fullest
only an eye set on the age to come
will make your work in this age
worth the crown of righteousness now i
have no doubt that you all have great
work in front of you that god
in his most gracious provision has
prepared for you to walk in
and i for one am excited just to see
just what you all will accomplish
in my fifth year here now here at
hillsdale college i'm delighted to have
so many friends who are alumni who have
gone this way before you and
i by god's grace been able to maintain
contact with them and see what they're
doing i hope
many of you will continue that with me
also
but i hope above all that when the world
speaks
of the people of this class hillsdale
college class of 2021
whatever else they say they will see an
abundance
of faith hope and love
and at the last you will see with the
same unflappable assurance as simeon
paul before you
lord now let us thou thy servant
depart in peace thanks
be to god
please stand
the lord be with you
let us pray
lord have mercy upon us
lord have mercy upon us our father
who art in heaven hallowed be thy name
thy kingdom come
uh
let us pray
i'm a father as we get ready to close
this chapter in our lives
i ask that you grant us a spirit of
sight
to be able to look back and see the
stories you have been writing
these past four weeks and as we remember
would you give us the grace to see you
like the embrace of our friends at the
lowest moments of college
you have been embracing us giving us the
courage to overcome our deepest
struggles
as our professors have given us grace
for all the late papers and assignments
you have been giving us grace patiently
working with our weaknesses
the hours of advice listening and loving
from mentors and families
[Music]
it is you who has written a story over
the past four years richer than anything
we could have asked for or imagine we
give you all the honor
and all the glory father
father you say unto us as you did to
joshua
i command you be strong and steadfast
do not fear nor be the same for the lord
your god is with you
wherever you go father
bless us with holy desire with an inward
fire that shines
light into the darkness of the future
that makes visible the is made possible
by grace
that blazes with the strength of your
divine love
bless us with courage and perseverance
with wisdom and compassion
with the willingness to follow you and
to find you
in the world we are about to enter
suffer us not to be separated from you
but remain within us
and before us always through your son
jesus christ
lord now and forever amen
now by the grace of almighty god may you
be filled with the knowledge of his will
of all
wisdom and understanding so as to walk
in a manner worthy
and may you be strengthened in the inner
man of all power
according to his glorious minds for all
endurance and patience
giving joyful thanks to him in all
things
and the blessing of god almighty the
father the son and holy spirit
oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
oh
[Music]
me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
a couple of quick notes for you all
before your dismissal as seniors you are
asked to please gather outside on the
steps of the chapel for your senior
class picture
uh immediately after the service
concludes you are free to depart at the
conclusion of the recession
everyone else is invited to please exit
the building through the side entrances
which you can get through the narthex
here
so the front of the building is free for
the senior picture
let us bless the lord thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you